Completa el cuadrado para resolver 4x cuadrada más 40 x -300 igual a 0.
Y si te das cuenta esto es un caso particular de lo que vimos en el vídeo pasado,
Así que déjame escribirlo aquí primero, para que no se nos olvide que es lo que queremos.
4x cuadrada más 40x -300 igual a 0 y yo lo que quiero es resolver esta ecuación
completando el cuadrado, y bueno en el vídeo pasado encontramos la solución general para las ecuaciones de segundo grado,
completando el cuadrado, por lo tanto voy a hacer lo mismo que hice en el vídeo pasado, y lo primero que hice fue dividir todo entre 4,
por lo tanto me va a quedar
4 entre 4 se van, ya cancele el término que está al lado de la "x" cuadrada y simple y sencillamente me queda "x" cuadrada
40 entre 4 me da 10, 10x y después me quedan -300
entre 4 y 0 entre 4 que es 0 pero, ¿Cuánto es 300 entre 4? Déjame hacerlo por aquí ,y además
sirve de que recuerdo cómo se hace una división de la manera tradicional.
Así que déjame ponerlo aquí 4 va a dividir a 300 y bueno 30 entre 4 me cabe 7 veces
7 por 4 28 y sobran 2, y después bajó el 0 y me queda 4 por 5 es 20,
entonces le quito 20 y me da 0, es exacta y me da 75
entonces - 75 es igual a 0 y ahora que ya cancele el coeficiente que estaba al lado de la "x" cuadrada,
entonces me va a ser mucho más fácil completar el binomio al cuadrado perfecto, lo primero que voy a hacer es pasar el
75 del otro lado de la ecuación y lo voy a pasar con signo positivo, o dicho de otra manera.
Lo que voy a hacer a continuación es sumarle a esta ecuación de ambos lados
75 positivo. Recuerda que lo que hago de un lado de la ecuación lo tengo que hacer también del otro lado,
y esto me va a servir para que yo pueda completar mi binomio cuadrado perfecto. Así que vamos a agregar
75 de ambos lados de la ecuación, cuando esto voy a poder eliminar el 75 y pasarlo del otro lado con signo contrario,
entonces a esto le voy a agregar 75 y al otro lado también le voy a agregar
75 y ¿Qué me queda? Me queda "x" cuadrada más 10x
75 y 75 se van, uno negativo y uno positivo, y del otro lado me queda simple y sencillamente 75.
Esto es igual a 75 y date cuenta que aquí dejé un espacio en blanco,
por que en este espacio en blanco voy a completar el binomio cuadrado perfecto y bueno,
ya que quiero completar el binomio cuadrado perfecto, recuerda que en este espacio en blanco lo que buscábamos, era tener el
cuadrado del segundo termino y quién es el cuadrado del segundo término bueno, para eso hay que encontrar el segundo término y bueno el segundo
término era muy fácil encontrarlo, tenemos que dividir simple
y sencillamente el coeficiente que está al lado de la "x" entre 2 es decir 10 entre 2 lo cual me da 5, y 5 si
lo elevó al cuadrado me va a dar 25
positivo entonces,  para yo tener un trinomio al cuadrado perfecto, aquí lo cual voy a poder factorizar en un binomio cuadrado perfecto,
tengo "x" cuadrada más 10x y a esto hay que agregarle 25 que es el cuadrado de la mitad de 10.
Recuerda que en el término que está al lado de la "x" tenemos que tener 2 veces el segundo término,
entonces ya estoy agregando 25 y si le estoy agregando 25 de un lado de la ecuación,
recuerda que también lo tenemos que agregar del otro lado de la ecuación, eso es muy
importante si queremos que la igualdad se mantenga o que la balanza quede equilibrada,
tengo que hacer lo mismo de ambos lados de la ecuación por lo tanto ¿Qué me va a quedar? "x" cuadrada más 10x
más 25 esto es lo mismo que "x" más 5 elevado al cuadrado, de hecho aquí estoy utilizando mi segundo término.
Fíjate que en efecto me queda esto, es el cuadrado del primero que es "x" cuadrada
más 2 veces el primero por el segundo que es 2 por 5 10, 10x más el cuadrado del segundo que es 25.
¡Perfecto! Hasta aquí vamos bien y después tenemos que sumar 75 más 25 en lo cual me da 100.
A continuación lo que voy a pasar es el cuadrado del otro lado de la ecuación
y voy a pasar el cuadrado con su operación
contraria, que es sacar raíz cuadrada.
Si yo saco raíz cuadrada del lado derecho en mi ecuación me va a quedar una raíz positiva y una raíz negativa, de este lado
Me va a quedar más menos 10 y del lado izquierdo simple y sencillamente me va a quedar "x" más 5, es decir
"x" más 5 es igual a la raíz cuadrada de 100 ¿Qué quién es? Es más
menos 10, no vayas a decir que es 10 por que entonces vas a tener la mitad de la respuesta
y bueno, ya aquí puedo encontrar las dos soluciones o "x" más 5 es igual a
10 positivo, o en su dado caso "x" más 5 es igual al -10 negativo y bueno, como yo lo que quiero es despejar a la "x"
entonces en ambas opciones lo que voy a hacer es restar 5 de ambos lados de la ecuación,
- 5 aquí y -5 acá, de tal manera que del lado izquierdo
solamente me queda "x" y del lado derecho me va a quedar 10-5 lo cual es 5, y aquí voy a hacer lo
mismo, voy a restar 5 de ambos lados de la ecuación.
De este lado izquierdo me queda simple y sencillamente "x" y del lado derecho me queda -15 y ya tengo mis 2 raíces.
¿Qué raíces? Que "x" igual a 5 y "x" igual a -15
solucionan esta ecuación de segundo grado, es decir que cuando yo
sustituyó la "x" por los valores de 5 y -15 en esta ecuación, en la ecuación original voy a obtener que el
resultado es igual a 0 o dicho de otra manera,
estas 2 son mis raíces de mi ecuación de segundo grado,
con la cual yo empecé y vamos a comprobar que en efecto es cierto. Voy a probarlo para la primera raíz
"x" igual a 5 entonces me queda 4  por 25 que es el cuadrado de 5 más
40 por 5 -300 y vamos a ver ¿A cuánto es igual esto? 4 por 25 es 100,
40 por 5 es 200 y después a esto le tengo que quitar 300 ¡Perfecto! Sí funciona con esta raíz.
Bueno pues si yo sustituyera el valor de 15 en esta ecuación también nos daríamos cuenta que nuestro resultado
sería igual a 0 y entonces nos vemos en el siguiente vídeo.